Collaborative calculator. I am really
excited to share this method. It's a
simple but profound answer to the
question: "How to keep someone
interested in a training or conversation?"
So, how do you keep people's attention?
Attention is the currency of the
world that we are living in, right?
There are so many places that our attention could
go at any given moment. And so, in order to really
capture somebody's attention, you've got to have
an amazing hook that brings people in and says,
"What's in it for me?" And so, mine right now,
in this moment, is by the end of this video,
you will have a method that you can use with 0
preparation that will, in the first 60 seconds
of any conversation or meeting any group workshop
setting, presentation that you can use to capture
everyone's attention, loop them
into your context, your purpose
and have people totally tunnel vision, tuned
in to what you have to say. Let's get into it.
To keep this video a little bit spicy and a little
bit interesting, I'm actually going to bring in
some live footage where I was facilitating
this collaborative calculator exercise
and framing it up with an actual group.
So, I was live, facilitating a virtual
workshop for 280 people on Zoom and what I want
to do is just show you how I played it out,
how I rolled it out in this setting and then
we'll cut back to me and debrief it a little bit.
So, collaborative calculator. What I would
love for you to do is open up the chat,
use only your number pad and think about the
month of March which is fastly approaching
and just drop an estimate of the
amount of time that you will spend
in virtual or hybrid meetings or gatherings. So,
in the month of March only,
can you drop an estimate...
and take a second like do an educated estimate and
can you drop that number in hours into the chat?
All right.
Yikes, 150. This isn't a competition, just so
you know. Romy, good to see you and 200+? What!
So, I learned was... and I meant to, before
the session, look up the actual research. Maybe
somebody can drop this in the chat if they know
the source of this, but I heard one so warning,
this is potentially not true but I think it is.
I... but it's not really
that of great consequence so,
I learned that when you guess the number of jelly
beans in a jar or the number of M&M's in a jar to
win a prize or something, you're probably gonna
be wrong. But if you ask a thousand people and
you take the average of everyone's answer, the
average is generally almost exactly correct.
I think I read that in a
book called "Group Genius,"
but that's kind of cool, right? So, number 1
calculation that I want to do is can somebody
just unmute, from looking up through the chat,
just like collaborative calculation, what do
you think the average is of all the numbers
that we're just typed in? 85. 70 to 90 is my best
guess. I didn't... I didn't catch you said 85,
but 75 to 90 we're like... whoever said 85, so
you said that was such conviction that we're
just gonna accept that as reality that is truth.
So, the average time that we will spend in virtual
or hybrid gatherings in March is 85. Can somebody
else do 227 x 85 on their calculator real quick?
And if you look down at Zoom, that's the amount
of human beings on this call. 227 x 85, and when
you as soon as you have that answer, unmute and
share it 19,295. 19,295. Will and I met working
for an... with an organization called World in
Conversation. One of their internal mottos was
"a tiny act can have profound effects." 19,000
hours. If you all take 1 little gem from this,
we have the bet... we have the option to make
the world 19,000 hours better just in March.
So, my invite is tune in and don't miss what's
about to happen in the next bit of time because
something really cool could end up in your
toolbox that you also carry way beyond March too.
Amazing, right? 1, just to get like a simple
number you could see, and I don't know if you
tuned into this, rewind if you didn't, but you
could see people's reactions and faces like, "Oh!"
right? There was... you actually
facially saw little light bulbs go
on in people's heads and I would say those
light bulbs were like, "Oh! This matters."
"Ooh! This is actually about..." right?
You want to create as many"Ooh!" "Ooh!"
as possible in the first few minutes of a training
or conversation. And if it's a longer event that
you're designing and a virtual conference or in-
person, you want to create those context hooks and
those attention resets multiple times throughout.
Because as soon as people start to see that maybe
this isn't for them or there's nothing in it for
them, they're going to be more likely to jump off.
And so bring people back to purpose with context
hook. Collaborative calculator is 1 method
that I happen to really like that I think works
great at the beginning, but if you want to keep
people's attention throughout (A) you should
maybe consider checking out this video on...
where I unpack 5 essential ingredients for virtual
engagement from the particular lens of how do I
encourage active participation in conversation.
So, that video is linked up here in that little
i thing. I'm not sure what that little
link embedded thing is in YouTube but
it's linked up there. If you choose to
open up that video and watch it later,
ingredient number 2 is this idea of a context
hook. And the idea is how can I... I don't love
the word "hook" because like fishing of a hook,
it's a little bit like, violent. I think about it
more like a Little Bo Peep's staff like the little
hook to like loop a sheep in like gently guide
somebody over toward you and invite them into
your context because if they're already in
the same space with you, they probably would
benefit greatly from being in your context,
they're just not yet, right? They're actually just
not there because they were thinking about this,
that and the third and they weren't actually
concerned and tuned in and paying attention to
what was happening live in the moment. An exercise
like collaborative calculator, a really great and
compelling intention statement or anything else
can help people... loot people into your context.
And that alone will help people tune in for the
rest of the time. If you made it to this video,
I suppose I have learned something
about how to keep attention because
you're still here. Thank you,
you're the kind of people I love hanging out with.
My name is Chad Littlefield, have an awesome day.